[موسيقى]
قطعه قطعه يسرد المحيط الهادئ في اعماقه
جانبا من احداث الحرب العالميه الثانيه اذ
اعلن باحثون من جامعه هواي والمركز
الامريكي للابحاث المائيه الشهر الماضي عن
عثورهم على اجزاء مهمه من غواصه يابانيه
مجهزه لحمل طائرات قتاليه غرقت بعد قليل
على انتهاء الحرب
العالميه لم يدرك الباحثون ميزه هذه
الغواصه الا عندما اكتشفوا ان المساحه
المخصصه للشحن في الغواصه التي يطلق عليها
اسم اي 400 كانت مخصصه لتسع ثلاث طائرات
برمائيه باجنحه قابله
للطي عندها قررت اليابان البحث عن
غواصتين بالبحث عن الحطام في المكان
المناسب ليجدوا القطعه العلويه من الغواصه
في حاله ممتازه بالنسبه لحطام انتزع من
الجزء الاساسي للسفينه على عمق يزيد عن
120 مترا في المحيط وتعد اي 400 واحده من
بين اكبر ثلاث غواصات صنعت قبل الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وقد صنعت في البدايه
كاسل الحه لمحاربه امريكا وكان يمكنها
بلوغ اي نقطه حول الارض دون الحاجه للتزود
بالوقود كما كان بامكانها تحميل ثلاث
طائرات كل واحده منها كانت قادره على حمل
ما يزيد عن 800 كيلوغرام من المتفجرات
[موسيقى]
ه